Actors get paid to pretend they’re someone
else, and when they’re totally overtaken
by their own performances, unexpected things
can— and will— happen.
Some of the best cinematic moments have come
from on-set surprises.
If you like what you’re about to see, head
over to our YouTube channel and take a look
at some of our other videos, and hit “subscribe”
if you like what you see.
Here are ten popular actors who lost control
and took it too far.
Seth Rogen, The Interview
Once a movie is released, the creators have
very little control over what happens next.
Sometimes it makes it all the way through
production and gets shut down just before
crossing the finish line.
Directors Seth Rogen and Evan Goldberg know
this all too well, and if you’ve ever heard
of 2014’s The Interview, then you do too.
The story centers on a producer and TV host
who travel to North Korea, and are given the
assignment to kill Kim Jong-Un.
As you can probably imagine, the real Kim
Jong-Un wasn’t a fan of the storyline.
And threatened retaliation if the movie were
to be released- saying all publicity for the
movie would be considered an act of terrorism.
Leonardo DiCaprio, Django Unchained
Over the course of his career, Leonardo DiCaprio
has cemented his reputation as a serious actor.
He’s a profitable Hollywood star and he’s
been in some of the best films of the past
decade.
While his roles have been varied, his turn
as Calvin Candie in Django Unchained was the
first time the renowned actor got to be the
bad guy.
And he was really, REALLY good at it.
DiCaprio got so deep into the character that
when he sliced his hand open on a broken glass
during one rant, he didn’t even notice.
Nothing looks better than the real thing,
so obviously Tarantino chose that take for
the final cut.
Isla Fisher, Now You See Me
Everyone loves a good underwater trick.
But because of their environment, safety crews
sometimes have a difficult time figuring out
where the acting ends and real distress begins.
During the filming of her scene in the opening
montage of Now You See Me, actress Isla Fisher
almost drowned after getting tangled up in
her submerged chains.
Since that’s also what’s happening to
her character at the time, people on set have
admitted to not knowing if Fisher needed assistance
for real, or if she was just a really great
actress.
Thankfully, the actress was able to untangle
her own chains before the situation turned
fatal.
George Clooney, Syriana
George Clooney is one of the most popular
actors in Hollywood history.
So, of everyone on this list, you might think
that production would work the hardest to
keep him safe.
But nevertheless, as we’ve seen before,
accidents have a way of happening regardless.
While filming a torture scene for Syriana,
the actor flipped his chair just a little
too hard, and the result was an injury so
horrific the actor has openly discussed how
the pain of it made him contemplate suicide.
The actor went some time without knowing what
was wrong, but after getting checked out it
was learned that he was leaking spinal fluid.
We’re not medical professionals, but even
we know that’s not good.
Like, really, really, not good.
Jason Statham, Expendables 3
Everything about Jason Statham screams “cool”.
His accent, attitude, and ability to kick
anyone’s ass are all intimidating traits,
to say the least.
Oh, and he does all his own stunt work.
Not many actors can say that.
Statham comes from a background of lower-budget
fare, and got used to the risky maneuvers.
But when filming Expendables 3, the actor
almost met his maker.
The stunt was rigged so that a truck he was
driving would stop, allowing him to get out
and start shooting.
Except that the truck didn’t stop.
And when it went over the edge into the black
sea, it took the actor with it.
This is where normal people might start pooping
their pants, but not Statham.
The former champion diver got out and swam
to safety like it was no big deal.
Channing Tatum, Foxcatcher
Channing Tatum has been in movies all over
the map.
The actor can handle comedy, drama, and action
to be sure.
For his role in Foxcatcher, the actor got
deep into character.
So deep that he actually put his face through
a mirror.
That’s right folks, Channing Tatum was so
devoted to the role that he put.
his.
face.
through.
a.
mirror.
And even though it was covered with a sheet
of plastic, the mirror was a very real one,
and resulted in very real lacerations that
bled very real blood.
The actor was so immersed in his performance
that he hardly noticed, but nobody on set
could look away.
Ryan Reynolds, Deadpool
With the exception of one movie where he dons
a fat suit, Ryan Reynolds has never looked
out of shape.
But that doesn’t mean he didn’t FEEL out
of shape.
No stranger to the world of comic book movies,
the actor was over the moon to be playing
Deadpool in a right, proper Deadpool story.
Reynolds was so stoked, in fact, that on the
first day of his Deadpool workout, the actor
went so hard that he put his back out first
thing.
The actor described literally crawling on
all fours home from the gym because of the
immense pain.
It’s not the first time he’s been injured
in the line of duty either, he also separated
his shoulder during filming on The Green Lantern.
Jeremy Renner, The Avengers
A large part of what makes superheroes “super”
is their ability to run into the middle of
a brawl and emerge relatively unscathed.
Sure, caped crusaders end up with some bumps
and bruises along the way, but they definitely
don’t see it as a reason to slow down.
Except that those near-invincible characters
are played by humans, and are therefore susceptible
to things like fatigue, injury, and full-on
incapacitation.
This is exactly what happened to mortal man
Jeremy Renner while filming The Avengers.
According to Joss Whedon, the actor hurt his
back and shoulder badly enough that the movie’s
production shut down for days afterward.
Chris Evans, Captain America: Civil War
Captain America is an all-around useful guy
to have on your team.
He’s in perfect physical condition, wields
a vibranium shield, is hella smart, and he’s
nice to boot.
Chris Evans plays him so well that it’s
hard to imagine a time where he wasn’t playing
The Captain.
It’s a role that has required the actor
to stay in shape for years at a time thanks
to the character’s prominence in the MCU.
That super-strength has its limits, though.
And as much as we’d like to believe that
Evans really CAN stop a helicopter mid-takeoff,
it’s just not the reality.
While performing the stunt where Cap’ holds
onto a rope to do just that, the prop helicopter
slipped in a direction it wasn’t supposed
to.
And as a result, the actor’s arm is messed
up— apparently it STILL hurts.
Margot Robbie, The Wolf of Wall Street
Margot Robbie’s career is so hot right now
that she could probably smack the pope and
get away with it.
But back when the actress was filming The
Wolf of Wall Street, she was a relative unknown.
Sharing a screen opposite Leonardo DiCaprio
is a noob’s worst nightmare.
That’s the guy from Titanic!
He’s a megastar!
We’ve heard how Robbie downed tequila in
preparation for a nude scene, but nothing
could have prepared her for another tense
moment on set.
In the heat of her performance, the actress
slapped DiCaprio in the face and yelled “fuck
you”.
After realizing that face was attached to
a multi-billion dollar celebrity, she worried
the actor might sue.
But quite the opposite happened— he was
so impressed that he insisted she do it again.
Margot Robbie just can’t lose.
So, did our video teach you anything new?
Did we skip over your favorite entry?
Tell us about them in the comments, and subscribe
to our YouTube channel for more awesome videos.